["Take Me By Your Side"]
Everyone has the same question,
and they always ask, hey, what should I expect?
Like, what's actually possible?
If I come in this program, I go through it,
like, what could I do?
How much money could I make?
How many deals could I get?
Okay, and I will tell you right now
that there are people in this program
that have already done this,
and in their first month, they have done eight deals.
No kidding, we have a student that got in
within 25 days, eight deals, okay?
We also have a student that took a little bit longer.
It took them five weeks to get a deal.
They got a deal for $5,400 per month, one single deal, okay?
So, the possibilities are great,
but I wanna set expectations,
just like you should with your clients, right?
Just when the business owner says,
hey, how many leads could I reasonably expect?
You're not gonna go and tell them,
hey, you know, I got this guy named Bob,
and he has this site, and it's getting 100 leads.
Cool, Bob has 100 leads,
but if you set the expectation for 100 leads,
you are going to be just dealing with a mess, okay?
So, I wanna set the expectations right here,
and the goal and the expectation is that within 30 days,
you should at least have your first deal,
and you need to realize, like,
I need you to get your deal in 30 days,
as bad as you need to get your deal in 30 days,
because that's how I grow, and once you get your deal,
I'm going to do an interview,
that's gonna be more social proof,
and that's just how this works.
So, I am very, very invested in this, just like you are,
because I need you to get deals,
but I just wanna set the expectation that,
I know some of you are gonna listen to that and go,
oh, one deal, like, that's it?
I got way bigger goals, that's cool,
and I'm really cool with that,
but here's what I understand,
is the first deal is the most important.
So, the goal is, and the expectation is,
follow the training, go through the modules,
do as I've instructed, okay?
Go through them, each one, and do exactly what it asks.
Don't just watch it, and then don't do anything.
Do exactly what it asks you to do,
and the expectation I have for you,
and you should have for yourself,
is that within 30 days, within the first month,
you are getting your very first flat fee deal.